[Music]
all right guys
there was this horrible ad that went out
from this major supermarket
chain well i wouldn't say horrible it's
just very um what's the term
disgusting insensitive insensitive
a death what that's the one i was trying
to think of tone deaf
whatever you don't know what that means
watering his mushroom log okay just
leave him alone let him do it let him do
what he's doing it wasn't in frame
there we go water it dips so big boy
wants to know what tone death means oh
tone death means like
when um like for example okay this one
so this this one ad
they ended up posting for thanksgiving
okay they said
hosting question mark plan a super
spread
that's incredible that's so good so so
right now we're in the right now we're
in the middle of attendance
that is so middle of a pandemic and you
know how like
big events they're calling them super
spreaders of of coronavirus
but then also a spread is when you lay
out oh i get what you're saying like
thingies
a lot of um i wasn't catching it at
first now i get it yeah they're like not
being aware of what's happening the
wording the word
what it's like it's like if there's an
overall understanding of what's going on
in the world and they go in the exact
opposite direction
right it makes sense that spread looks
good with it like the pepsi ad that's
like i feel like the ideal definition of
like tone death
what was the pepsi out again my life is
toned down kendall jenner all the
protests and stuff that were happening
and then
like she comes out with like a pepsi and
it gives it to the cops and then
everyone's celebrating yeah
oh now we're all we're all together now
that we have a pepsi
it's like come on switching
[Applause]
he's only drinking that because it was
free okay he's the opportunist his go-to
is rockstar because it's always the
[ __ ] deal
whenever dollar can all the time that's
right
why don't you just get the big packs
because then that's the real deal
i do that too they sell two liter
monsters or like two liter
in my dream world they do my two liter
mods i don't know
the biggest ones are the refillable
right with the syllables that's the
biggest one
but they don't make the they don't make
the absolute zero of that so i can't
[ __ ] with it
what's yeah they do the white one sugar
ultra no if the
do they yeah they do that oh i didn't
see that oh they changed his world like
this
you're only gonna buy those now thank
you guys wait doesn't it taste better
out of a can versus a bottle though no
it's a still can but a resealable can oh
cool
yeah that's tight okay anyway back to
this so giant
this supermarket chain a major
supermarket chain
on the east coast they have they have
locations like maryland
virginia delaware and dc
they uh they ended up posting this
online
and they were saying that they they did
apologize
they weren't trying to be insensitive
whoever does try to
[ __ ] idiots the idiots are the ones
who got mad
like like i can't believe you would say
that
this shrimp cocktail is a super spreader
like
like come on bro that's true that'll be
you funny commercials
absurd yeah oh yeah well no if it was a
commercial they did intentionally they
they get way more backlash because
seeing how everyone's getting offended
oh yeah just for like this like
innocent it seems innocent they were
just like
it's innocent like having a cheese tray
and saying it's just
it's a super spread is like the most
innocent thing you can think of yeah
see it just says plant or hosting plan
is super spread
it's easy with our entertaining
offerings order platters
trays entrees desserts and more now you
can share
corona with your loved ones and maybe
you can go viral
we provide a really big dipping sauce
container so you can double dip
and share the love all around double dip
damn
that's a real super spread are you guys
gonna do thanksgiving
like with family and all that and uh
no i will be doing it with friends
though friendsgiving yeah
my family and i were debating on what to
do we were in between
like uh either like just zooming it or
zoom a thanksgiving yeah i mean hanging
out just because i
my parents are old now my mom's like a
super super high risk
uh so we're either gonna do that or
we're gonna have like a lunch
uh so we make sure that it's warm enough
to be outside and make sure we have
tables that are kind of separate so you
can like my mom
and dad can be on their own little table
and then we can be over there so we can
still talk like
with distance with megaphones yeah
yeah they're in the backyard we're in
the front yard and we're gonna scream
over the house that's great yeah that's
fantastic
how about you um
[Music]
not sure yet but yeah probably with the
fan something you know because my
[ __ ] dad has a pre-existing condition
if not for him if not for him i'd be
going down to san diego and seeing
everybody
yeah because i don't think we're gonna
meet up either because
um we have some old guy
near the death [ __ ] i'm like dad
why'd you have to
eat so much mcdonald's in the 90s that
you have [ __ ]
type 2 diabetes now you [ __ ] you were
thinking of yourself
i know my mom has diabetes too so i
can't see her
wait my uncle has diabetes too so we
can't see him
damn just diabetes man diabetes
i don't even understand my dad's logic
because uh i
he called me yesterday it was my birth
yesterday i'm like hey dad i'm gonna
come over for dinner he goes no no we
gotta
stay away from each other for like
corona stuff but then
randomly he just shows up at the house
so i'm like i don't understand like
should i surprise you yeah i don't know
what it is
because his rules don't really make
sense he's like if i can surprise you i
can surprise the virus
[Laughter]
thursday he came over to play with taika
and he was there for like three hours
and then so i'm like you wear his mask
the whole time no
i don't know what is you know what's
funny too is i remember watching
as a child i watched all of the patterns
that turned into my dad's diabetes he's
like have you ever had a bear claw and
i'm like
no and then he's like oh they're
delicious and he's like oh i like apple
fritters and then he's like
oh yeah big mac i always get the number
one i remember
all that so distinctly in that does he
love fair food
oh yeah oh yeah yeah deep fried oreos
funnel cake yeah yeah yeah yeah fried
egg
like deep fried butter my uncle suffered
his way to diabetes like your dad
actually
partied he enjoyed it he enjoyed his
diabetes journey right
but my uncle was like yo i'm gonna eat
salad
i'm gonna eat like no meat cause he
thought that meat was gonna
[ __ ] him up and then so he's like just
eating vegetables and then
he gets hungry because vegetables are
all [ __ ] up right it's like there's
nothing in there yeah so then he um
starts eating instant noodles five bowls
of rice
yeah you know to feel full and [ __ ] and
then so he's like man i'm eating healthy
i'm like oh really goes yeah i just ate
these three packets of ramen
and like i bought i ate all these green
beans and
i'm like that sounds like a lot of carbs
dude so he
thought he was being healthy all the way
up until the end until he got diabetes
so he suffered his way into it man at
least my dad got to enjoy it unlike the
people who are born with diabetes and
they're just like i don't even do
anything oh
how did they get it their parents yeah
their parents fault man
damn that sucks crazy it's such a
different understanding between
normal people who eat food and people
who like go through fitness because then
you kind of understand like carbs and
protein like what each thing is and how
many calories something is
so like people are like oh this is dirty
and that's not dirty but then they'll
eat like a ton of that thing that's
clean but now you have all this sugar
like from juice like juice is the same
thing as sugar i mean the same thing as
like soda right
yeah yeah so people like have all these
ideas of like yeah
1200 calorie healthy smoothie yeah yeah
because the food pyramid was such a joke
and it taught everyone oh like
juice is like fruit and so yeah my uh
brother found out he was type 1 diabetes
in his 40s
wow he was like always wondering why he
was tired and [ __ ] so he was born with
that [ __ ]
yeah he never knew because he always had
a weird like appetite
or he would get tired and like he didn't
know that he had it because my dad
actually has type two
me too and then my uncle has it like it
runs in my family so i can probably get
it
if i don't watch it don't they like [ __ ]
test it in your blood and [ __ ] like for
type one
growing up i guess not for him yeah
because i mean we only went to the
doctor when we were sick
or like really bad we didn't go for
regular checkups and you didn't go to
get a booster shot and all that [ __ ]
no what you can insert things into my
body but take nothing out yeah
well i guess that's a baby yeah my mom
got it through pregnancy
on one of my like when she was pregnant
with one of my brothers because she just
kept eating bear claws
eating so much you're eating a ton of
sugar and all that yeah i don't
know what happens for you to get it
maybe
it is that because that seems to make
sense but diabetes was a sugar
thing yeah for my old man but it depends
because you could be born with it like
he was saying
you get type 1 but type 2 when you when
it's when it's induced it's usually
because it's over
sugar right and i don't know what type
it is i don't know what it's called
but also they're saying that the baby
like my brother for example
he has a higher risk of something about
diabetes and so does casey because his
mom had it when she was pregnant with
casey too
so damn diabetes did they get better
right when they had the baby or was it
like a long like
i don't remember but i remember my mom i
don't remember like after but i remember
her being pregnant and she would like
like prick her belly like she would like
do some [ __ ] with her belly
i don't know i think she would like give
insulin or i don't know whatever yeah
cause normally you
you do that right you grab your the fat
of your skin and you inject it there
yeah but she had like a big old pregnant
belly and she was like injecting her
belly
damn that's scary i don't know i was
like 10. so i don't really remember
we're like mom you're going to pop your
stomach but yeah
i remember thinking that and i think i
asked her that even because i was like
what's going to happen to the baby
but yeah i don't know it's crazy but
yeah this super spreader ad
it got viral obviously i think it did
what it wanted to do
right like everybody's talking about i
think they did it on purpose just to
kind of like get a little
controversy i don't know if they
purposely tried to like make people mad
i bet they were they thought it was
funny like we thought it was funny yeah
um but like i think it's working just
like the pepsi [ __ ] right like no one's
going
i mean i bet people said at the time but
a lot of people now they're not like i'm
not gonna drink pepsi ever because they
were insensitive
right it's like oh yeah pepsi like the
whole point of ads is that it's not
to make you think that it's good right
most ads are like oh yeah it's still
there just to make you remember yeah
like twix
left and right twigs that doesn't make
you want to eat it but you're like twix
is still a thing
wait left and right to it yeah that's
like their main ad i think they're
always like i'm team left twix i'm team
right twix what no one [ __ ] cares
but it's just so that you can see that
it exists
like one of the tricks is like
republican that was democrat
sure weird damn advertising
that's crazy i gotta learn these tricks
for your mushroom
well first you gotta know what your
actual code is um
mk dot farm slash joe you could get 10
off
did you confirm it yet though nah just
type it in
mk dot farm slash joe you get your own
mushroom farm four or four found nothing
i should throw this in the middle of a
protest and see if it will like chill
things out
that's smart yeah yeah in the middle of
a thanksgiving feast
yeah like hey corona chill out yeah hey
why'd you throw a log in my head man
what the [ __ ] dude i'm trying to
increase the peace with mushroom and
[Music]
nature
[Music]
you